let's think a little bit about the
metric the metric system units for
volume or essentially how much space
something is taking up in three
dimensions so the base unit in the
metric system for volume is the leader
is the leader and there's a couple of
ways that you can visualize a leader one
way you could think about a leader is if
you took a cube if you took a cube that
is 10 centimeters 10 centimeters deep
10 centimeters wide and 10 centimeters
tall then this amount of space that
you're taking up this volume this volume
is one liter so this right over here is
one liter
another way to connect it to our
everyday lives is you've probably gone
and bought or your parents have bought a
two-liter bottle of something oftentimes
it's soda so this right or those two
liter bottles are as I just mentioned
these are 2 litres so let me my best
attempt to draw what those bottles look
like they look something like they look
something like this at least in the US
you oftentimes so2 and other things will
be sold in these in these two liter in
these two liter bottles so if you take
half of this you are looking at a liter
more so this so liter would be about
half of this so if it's half full a
liter would be about that much and
hopefully that is consistent or that
makes sense relative to this 10
centimeter by 10 centimeter by 10
centimeter 10 centimeter cube now if you
want to measure things that are a lot
smaller than a liter the typical unit
used and obviously in the metric system
you can always use the prefixes deci
centi but the one that's most typically
used is the milliliter milli the mili
liter and we've already seen the prefix
milli it means one thousandth so this
means one thousandth one thousandth of a
one thousandth of a liter or another way
of thinking about it is one liter is
equal to one thousand
1,000 milliliters mili mili liters and
if you wanted to visualize what a
milliliter looks like imagine taking a
cube instead of making it 10 centimeters
on each dimension make it only one
centimeter in each dimension so one
centimeter wide one centimeter one
centimeter deep one centimeter wide and
one centimeter high and then you're
looking at a milliliter and if you want
to think about the type of things that
are measured in milliliters you might
think things about dosage of medicine so
for example a typical a teaspoon that
you might see in your cabinet is going
to be a little bit over four milliliters
almost five milliliters so that might be
good for medicine dosage or maybe small
ingredients in some type of a recipe if
you want to go larger than a liter and
once again you could use all the metric
prefixes you could use dekaliter you
could use hectolitre but the one that's
most typically used is kiloliter kill a
liter kill Oh a liter and as the prefix
kilo implies this is equivalent to 1,000
1,000 liters and if you want to
visualize this you can this actually
isn't as large as you might assume it to
be if you just take a cube and this side
and instead of taking each dimension
being 10 centimeters if you were take a
cube where each dimension is exactly 1
meter each dimension is exactly one
meter so one meter deep one meter wide
and one meter tall this volume is
equivalent to one kiloliter one kilo
liter so you can imagine something like
a kiloliter
would be very useful for measuring say
the volume of water inside of a of a
swimming pool